All right. Hi there, CNN.
We're here with award-winning
media contributor
to ABC News, US Today,
and The Hill, Donna Brazile,
and former Illinois congressman
and author of Renegade,
Adam Kinzinger.
Okay, here are the questions...
(APPLAUSE)
...that people, uh...
"Any guesses on
the next candidate to drop out
of the Republican presidential
primary?"
-DeSantis.
-BILL MAHER: Yeah.
I think it's DeSantis.
He's collapsing.
I think he's next.
What happened there?
He was doing so well
as a Florida governor.
He was everyone--
I advised him, publicly,
I said, "Don't run."
First of all, no one's
gonna take it from Trump.
You're 44. You can do this
for the next--
Biden, next 40 years.
(LAUGHTER)
His problem is he was--
he was-- he was trying
to be Donald Trump.
His play was Donald Trump's
gonna fall out, you know,
with the case or whatever,
and he would be there
to inherit that.
It was a bad play
because Donald Trump's
not going anywhere.
And he has no personality.
He's literally one of the most
boring guys
-I've ever worked with.
-(LAUGHTER)
And I mean that
with a straight face.
Terribly boring.
Well, I think North Dakota
Governor Doug Burgum
will drop out.
-I think Asa Hutchinson--
-ADAM KINZINGER: I didn't know
they were still in it.
-I think they dropped out.
-No, no, no. They're still in.
You said, "Who's next?"
No, they did.
Well, they're not in the debate.
But they're in the debate.
Right.
And-- And then, I also believe
that Chris Christie
has to prove himself.
And Vivek needs to just
shut the hell up and go home.
-I'm tired. Oof.
-(APPLAUSE)
ADAM: We all hate Vivek.
Okay. It's Vivek.
Well, whatever.
Vivek needs to sit--
Whatever? Would you say that
about other--
Donna. I'm Donna. Vivek.
Is it Vi-vek Ramaswama?
(LAUGHTER)
-Ramaswamy?
-Vivek Ramaswamy.
Thank you so much.
I learn so much
-when I come on this show.
-BILL: I know.
(LAUGHTER)
-DONNA BRAZILE: Vivek?
-Vivek.
Vivek needs to go home.
(LAUGHTER)
-I agree.
-He runs it-- He's...
I just feel like there's
something wrong with everybody
refusing to learn
to say his name.
DONNA: Vivek. Okay, I won't--
I just feel like there's
a little racism there.
-It's just a little--
-There's no racism.
ADAM: Vivek, Vivek. I'll say it.
-Ramaswamy, I'll say it.
-BILL: I'm just saying,
it just feels like--
I know we don't like him,
but just say his name right.
You're the first one
I've ever heard say that.
-I always thought it was--
-BILL: I could be wrong.
Maybe it's not Vivek.
No, it is. It is Vivek
because I heard him do a rap,
and he said it rhymes
with "cake."
Okay, all right. All right.
(LAUGHTER)
This is what the CNN audience
needs to know.
(LAUGHTER)
All right, are you surprised
that the Republican share
of the House Ethics Committee
is now pushing
for George Santos
to be expelled from Congress?
Okay, there's another one
of your-- Did you work--
Yeah, no. I'm not surprised.
I mean, look, it's--
BILL: Did you work with him?
George Santos?
-No, thank God.
-(LAUGHTER)
-He came after me. Yeah.
-He came after you, okay.
But the-- the, uh...
So they're down to
whatever it is,
three- or four-vote majority
now.
The Republican majority
is doing nothing else
the rest of the year.
They'll have to deal with
keeping the government open.
Please, God, they can get
Ukraine aid done.
That's gonna be
really important.
Ukraine, Israel, et cetera.
But they're not going to do
much else.
So now, you're at a point
where a four- or a three-vote
majority is pointless.
And he's become a huge anchor.
I think even this finally
crosses a red line for them.
And I think they'll vote
to expel him.
He's an embarrassment
to the institution itself.
I'm a former
Congressional staffer,
but Bill, when I looked at
that list of things
he spent campaign money on.
I mean, all the years
I run campaigns,
I never thought
I could just take
a little drive-by to Sephora
or get a little...
(LAUGHTER)
Get a little Botox
and a little lift.
ADAM: He's like the only--
He's the only, like,
campaign finance scandal
I've ever seen
that didn't even try
to launder the money
through something else.
He literally just took it,
put it in his bank account,
and got an OnlyFans.
It was like...
-Yeah, OnlyFans.
-Yeah!
I mean, Trump wears a lot
of makeup.
-But I assume...
-(LAUGHTER)
-Well, he does.
-Yeah, he does.
I mean, he's always under
two pounds of bronzer.
That's the natural glow
of somebody who's already hot.
He's going to hell.
(APPLAUSE)
Adam, as a Republican
who stood up extremists
in your party,
what advice do you have
for Democrats who are trying
to combat the far left.
Okay, listen.
This is the best thing,
because I... There was a guy.
He was a Californian,
Dana Rohrabacher, that was like
the only pro-Russian Republican
-for a while.
-BILL: I remember him.
And people-- I'd take him on in
the Foreign Affairs Committee,
and people would say,
"Just let it, you know...
He's just one person.
He's probably being paid by
the FSB." Right? Whatever.
Well, that crazy ends up,
like, overtaking the party.
The crazy of--
You know, nobody imagined
Donald Trump in 2014.
You've got to kill extremism
in the cradle,
or it takes over.
Because if you re--
if you look at your coalition
and say,
"We need this extre--
We need the pro-Hamas faction,"
or "We need the, you know,
the anti-Russia faction--
or the pro-Russia faction,"
they end up calling the shots.
Because if everybody
in this room has a grenade,
right,
we're all equally powerful.
If somebody's willing
to pull the pin,
they're the most powerful person
in the room.
And extremists are willing
to pull the pin.
You have got to be willing to,
I don't know,
pull the pin with them
or whatever.
You've got to be willing
to fight back.
Did you ever hear that tape
of Paul Ryan, Kevin McCarthy,
and Steve Scalise
talking about Rohrabacher
and Trump?
Yeah! Yeah, yeah.
Okay, if people
don't remember this.
And this is-- The fact that
this doesn't get more play.
I mean, this is years ago.
But this is on tape!
-ADAM: Yep.
-And one of them says,
"I think there's two people
on Putin's payroll.
One of them is Rohrabacher
and one of them is Trump."
And the-- the other two
don't go,
"Oh, my God!
Let's do something about it."
They say, "This stays
in the family, right?"
-ADAM: Yep. Yep.
-DONNA: Mm-hmm.
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
(LAUGHTER)
Hell! I told you,
that's where you go.
It went better in rehearsal,
but still good.
(LAUGHTER)
No, but it is--
That is kind of amazing.
-DONNA: Yeah. Yeah.
-ADAM: Yeah.
But Bill, any form of extremism
must be denounced.
We must condemn those
who are marching,
saying that what Hamas did
on that horrific day was right.
-We should immediately call...
-BILL: Right. Of course.
...for Hamas to release
the hostages.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
I mean...
BILL: Well, we are.
We're calling for it.
-What...
-No, but we have to demand that.
You see people marching--
BILL: What do you mean,
"demand"?
Why do you think
Israel is attacking?
They don't just respond
to your demands.
I'm talking about
people who are protesting.
They're protesting,
and they are saying,
"Leave Hamas alone."
-And I'm like,
no, Hamas started this.
-BILL: Of course.
ADAM: It's a cancer
that needs eradicated.
-It's a cancer.
-BILL: So interesting.
They did a poll of the people
who live in the area
from, uh, they're say--
they're saying
"the river to the sea."
-In other words, Israeli Arabs.
-DONNA: Yeah.
They don't want to live
under Hamas.
Nope. Nope.
That-- 77 percent of them said,
"No thanks.
We're living in Israel.
It's way better than living
under a terrorist group."
Yeah, why don't you
teach that at college?
(APPLAUSE)
Okay. What do you think
of prominent Democrats
like David Axelrod
calling for Biden to, quote,
"Get out or get going."
Did he say that,
"Get out or get going"?
Uh, I believe in the tweet
or two and some stuff.
Look, people that Joe Biden is--
is perhaps too old.
-They're right.
-BILL: Perhaps.
(LAUGHTER)
Don't-- Don't spill the water.
Something might come out of it.
Um...
(LAUGHTER)
It's not that--
You know,
everyone ages differently.
I agree.
I have said-- I've--
And, you know,
so Betty White lived to be 99.
Mick Jagger is still
twisting his ass.
ADAM: Mr. T.
Mr. T is still going.
I have been the one
making that case
year after year here
against ageism.
I always said
it's a case-by-case basis.
DONNA:
It's a case-by-case basis.
But for that argument
to have teeth,
you also have to be
the person who can go,
"Yeah, but this is the case."
And it-- I have said it before.
Do I think Joe Biden
can do the job?
-Absolutely.
-DONNA: Yes.
I don't think
he can win the job.
And that's what I care about.
He's going to lose
because the people think
he's too old.
And perception is reality,
I'm sorry.
He's been counted out
so many times,
I can't--
I've just lost track.
But look how many elections
since 2020 that he's won.
Last week, he was counted out,
and Democrats won.
He was counted out a year ago
in the Midterm.
Do not count out Joe Biden,
that's all I'm saying.
Okay, but on the subject
of people getting older
and they have to adjust,
some tragic news this week.
Snoop Dogg said
he's quitting pot.
-Yeah! I saw that.
-(LAUGHTER)
I know. I--
What's the secret?
What happened?
I posted a black square.
(LAUGHTER)
Well, I mean, that-- that is--
And I remember him
sitting right here
and me telling him,
this is about 10 years,
12 years ago,
and I said, "Snoop, I love you,
and you know we're both
pot brothers,
but you smoke too much pot."
(LAUGHTER)
-Yeah, because he's always
on Instagram smoking pot.
-BILL: Right.
He doesn't even
open up his Instagram
until he's smoking pot.
ADAM: Can I tell you,
the funniest thing
about his statement was--
I didn't know if he was serious
because at the end it,
he's like,
"I'm giving up the smoking,"
he goes, "Please respect
my privacy in this time."
And I was like...
(LAUGHTER)
-Really?
-ADAM: Yeah!
I was like, "Did somebody die?"
(LAUGHS)
My prediction-- my prediction
is it'll go the way it went
when my friend Woody Harrelson--
Woody Harrelson
said a number of times
he was gonna give up pot,
and then it was always,
"Welcome home, son."
(LAUGHTER)
All right. Thank you very much.
We'll see you next week.
(APPLAUSE)